the group traveled to Saudi Arabia for  an Islamic pilgrimage on the  twenty-eighth of May 12 days later ten  of them boarded a flight from Medina to  Istanbul in Turkey and since then  there's been no sign of them however  there are no records of two of the  children boarding the flight sisters her  fear bint zubair who's eight and  five-year-old Nura been sober since then  the group's mobile phones have not been  active and they haven't posted any  updates on social media the whole group  was due to arrive back in the UK on the  11th of June but didn't arrive one of  the possibilities is that they travel to  Turkey in order to reach Syria where  it's believed one of their brothers  could be police are now looking into  this